so hello everyone my name is Patrick Wu
I'm gonna be talking about single page
applications at scale so gonna turn up
that flux capacitor and yeah with 1.21
gigawatts we should get started but a
little bit about me I'm a software
development manager at AWS
we're building something super secret
confidential stuff for a project called
beehive and I love basketball and I love
movies from the 80s and also we are a
sponsor so super excited to be really
helping to contribute to this community
super excited about all the speakers
here and yeah
but what do I mean by Spa at scale like
what do I mean by single page
applications at scale well our project
is about two hundred thousand lines of
code and this is not a codified
compressed version but this is like pre
transpiled versions of our actual
application with over 50 front-end
engineers working on the project across
Seattle San Francisco Cupertino and
Vancouver so we have a very distributed
team we're all very very very excited
about our launch but we had a few bumps
along the way so let's go back in time
and I want to talk to you about our top
five lessons learned so far unless team
one was first getting to know our
customers so a lot of the times as
engineers we're working or like how this
works and it works it works on my
machine it works on Chrome I'm good
right but actually our customers are
also on edge Firefox Safari and I just
found out maybe some of them are a
beaker today so cross browser
compatibility is an actual thing and you
might say well Patrick these are
evergreen browsers they all complied
right they all should work right well
actually on we face this problem
recently we're trying to get our
performance metrics working and on
Firefox version 62 62 we observe without
observer was throwing an error right and
we had to solve that so we had to
actually fit
stat and address that for that issue but
they addressed it in version 63 but 60
is actually long term support and you're
saying well that's not they solved in a
version 63 right so that should that
should do the job but actually on some
corporate environments not everyone has
the latest version of that particular
browser so we have to really think about
those users as well as we're building
something at scale the other thing is
operating system issues so Mac PC we use
libraries and frameworks like react view
ember forgot to include that thing it
angular Babel plugins to help address
cross browser browser compatibility
issues but don't think that things will
just work and you know this is the thing
that we really learned a prime example
was we didn't know scroll bars display
on PCs we're all on Macs and so we have
to manually enable having it display by
default on Mac which was you know you're
saying well that's not a big issue right
but actually if we use a virtual I
scroll this kind of happens that one
pixel deviation was actually causing
performance issues where the virtualized
list was just kept on moving up and down
and all of the people on on the business
side who had pcs were complaining about
our app not functioning so yeah we had
to really consider that operating
systems the other thing was testing for
great experiences also include slow
connections right so what's awesome with
the chrome dev tools I know many of you
are familiar with this but this was
really revealing for us was people are
on slower connections that are not Wi-Fi
and high-speed so we had really had to
test to see if our actual application
functions on slower connections on a 3G
connection etc the other thing was to
even think about the actual machines so
we have as engineers high-powered
MacBook Pros and that's awesome but some
people are also on slower machines so
really thinking about throttling our CPU
to really cut simulate those
environments so there's also some great
tools that we really learned about to
test connectivity and some of those
tools are an open source project called
webpage tests that we run internally to
really test
our application so to simulate like a
cable connection or a 3G connection etc
and another really cool tool that we
really learned was lighthouse so that
was also allowing us to kind of see
simulated experience as well and it has
a really great accessibility score which
is really awesome as well the last
second lesson that we learned was about
documentation documenting our code so
one of the reasons we learned that was
as we've got new engineers again 50
engineers and we're keep growing and we
have to keep shoulder tapping people
like what does this component do and
documentation is absolutely pivotal to
the project but it's really hard it's
hard to maintain it's hard to understand
and it's difficult to scale like you
would change a particular function and
you wouldn't go back to your sort the
documentation to actually update it it
happened way too frequently so we
thought how can we solve this problem
one of the things we we introduced was
and I know some people might might not
like this but we actually you know ended
up using typescript and talk to
typescript was actually helped us with
doc you like having documentation in
code because it allows for
self-documenting code by providing great
IDE support like the autocomplete on on
that where for our props were pretty
amazing type checking misspelling a
component name would help us would
surface those things a lot quicker
required props provide a nice error
message and then helps us easily
refactor by renaming our component so
it's not like a search and replace but
it'll actually help us rename our
components for the ones that were
actually working on the other thing was
that typescript interfaces allows us to
be explicit about our component props
and surface details about a components
for all consumers so one of the things
that we do is we have distributed teams
and when we talk about the components
that we're going to build we talked
about it through our interfaces that we
first build so that was kind of a really
helpful thing for us to kind of document
so this all goes back to you know that
awesome book that we all might have read
which is clean code but the actual
author of the code of this quote is Gary
bouche not Uncle Bob and it's clean code
is simple direct and clean code should
read like well print prose so and that's
what we're hoping
you move more towards by adopting
typescript but that's great for our
engineering teams but it doesn't really
work for some of our business
stakeholders and our designers that we
work with and interact with so how can
we all be on the same page as well so
the thing that we adopted was a
storybook storybook for our react
component sir's rocks
and it's super awesome it allows us to
host documentation about our components
it provides a single source of truth for
designers product owners and our
engineers so one of the problems is why
this was really pivotal for us was we
would get a spec and it's continuously
iterating and I would I would talk to
the designer said hey Bob like what's
the what's the what's the file is this
the actual file they're like yeah that's
that's the actual final file I'm like
are you sure this is actual find a file
all right let me reach out to Sandra and
Sandra's like no this is the ultimate
final file for sure and there's no I I
don't know why they don't have code
version maybe they do but they don't
have a git for designer so it was really
hard to find the source of truth so that
was really challenging at least for us
so what we ended up doing is story book
was allow allowed for a great workflow
with our design systems and our single
source of truth so what we we have is we
incorporated Airbnb Syriac sketch at and
we could generate sketch symbols from
our actual react components to share
with the design teams so engineer would
build a react component generators
guests assembled hand that off to the
design team and they continuously
iterate upon that hand that off to us
and then we can continuously increment
upon that and actually deploy that to
production and again that's kind of a
single source of truth so that
everyone's on the same page and the
beautiful part it's version controlled
by a git so that's awesome as well
lesson three is tests this might be
obvious but it's actually one of the
most like foundational pieces for us
like testing might seem obvious easy but
I emphasize this as a lesson learned
because it helped us gain confidence in
our code a lot of times we would deploy
to prod and we didn't really have too
much confidence because we we thought I
worked on a machine again like the cross
browser compatibility issues but we had
we reduced a lot introduced a lot of
regressions also reduced the time
to first commit for our new hires so we
would get new hires and they would
because the code was you know fairly
well tested it was actually easier for
them to on board and you know within the
first 1 to 2 days they were actually
able to commit and we have a
foundational basis well also it reduces
having to paying different engineers to
try to find out what's going on and the
testing framework that we ended up using
was just jess is actually really great
for what we do it enables us to write
unit tests with just with enzyme it also
allows us to write integration tests and
it also allows us to have components tab
shot tests to kind of give visibility
into whether are that particular
component has changed so this is from
testing JavaScript comm which is an
amazing resource but it basically kind
of goes over the different pieces so
with static tests you know to catch
typos and errors we would actually use
typescript for that unit we're using
Jess integration we're using just again
an end-to-end we're playing and
experimenting with possibly using Jess
with puppeteer but again puppeteer only
is supported on Chrome so that's kind of
one of the issues that we're kind of
looking into so again I just really want
to highlight how awesome testing
JavaScript comm is a great resource by
Kent C Dodds and other amazing
contributors so definitely we're
checking out but things can still break
in production so we have your awesome
pipeline test right you got hey you know
from you know this particular
environment to this particular
environment to prod like it went through
code coverage I got 80% I'm good
integration tests they're all passing
and my end to end tests are passing so I
should be good and I don't have to worry
about prod and actually as an
engineering manager this is my interview
question right so pro tip here things
can still break in production and we
need to still think about our customers
while they're in production so what do
we do we actually have monitors and
alarms to provide visibility into our
production health for applications to
ensure that the deployments and the
dependencies are there so for example
your CDN might go down don't you want to
get visibility into whether that
actually happens and that's kind of one
of the things that we learn
as well and the other thing is we just
we were very focused on our customers we
don't want to kind of have them be our
manual QA team so again that's the
reason why we're focused on monitoring
so now we get we use specifically cloud
watch in our case AWS right so that
helps us collect monitor and act and
analyze on our actual metrics because as
Kyle Simpson a functional light
JavaScript mentions code that you cannot
trust is code that you don't understand
and I always say also in the same like
theme code that you do not test or you
haven't tested it's really code that you
don't really understand as well so
that's one of the things that we learned
all right
lesson for yakhni
now I don't know if any of you are
familiar with the term but it's popular
term coined among the engineering
communities but it means you ain't gonna
need it and as engineers we kind of have
a tendency to fall into tunnel vision we
tend to get stuck in tunnel vision over
optimizing like I you know this has to
really I'm trying to reduce time to
interact is I'm trying to get that first
meaningful paint time down and I'm
trying to reduce a look at the memory
heap that Patrick this is ridiculous we
need to reduce this is this is a and we
just kind of rathole
into this particular protect perspective
instead of like seeking feedback early
and often in topic pieces so just like
in your code reviews where you have an
atomic commit and you you send out a
code review for that and like a pull
request whatever and it's an atomic bite
sized piece and you want to see feedback
early and toughness so that you're not
creating a massive like 20 page code
review write or pull requests so that it
actually helps provide context in the
same sense in terms of our deployments
we want to really think about the the
features that we're building yes I do
believe performance is important but
first you got to capture metrics on that
- you want to get it into like these
tiny atomic pieces so you can get
feedback early from your customers to
know how to move forward because your
customers and the business are eager to
help avoiding wasting dev cycles that's
kind of the things that we learn so all
we need to do is really just stop and
because who knows uh-huh you might have
already built something really cool
right
one one note about this slide is I
always wondered did this kid really
happy that he broke the the scooter but
I mean he looks kind of happy about
getting a skateboard but again yeah
anyways all right
the biggest lesson and you know I think
if you take away anything of those four
lessons that that we learned that I
really want to share with this group is
that is this one and it just take away
this biggest lesson and that is to be
kind rewind right so you know earlier in
the day there used to be a place where
we would go right to a place and you
would you would just go through the
aisles and pick out something like a
nice movie and then you you go to the
checkout line grab a patch pack of sour
patch kids and maybe a pop and then you
go home and then you you you enter this
little block thing into this other
device and you hit play and boom you're
able to watch an amazing movie and it
was awesome and at the end of it there's
this always on this on this particular
thing you would see be kind rewind and
you know because you want to be
thoughtful about that next person who's
gonna want to enjoy this movie you would
actually be kind and rewind most of the
time unless you're super lazy and the
reason I harp on this is because you
know a lot of us as engineers they you
know in my case I've met amazing
engineering managers and mazing
technical leads amazing software
engineers who were shield empathy and
was able to kind of work with me they
were like you know when they showed
empathy when they were reviewing my code
they showed empathy when I was trying to
learn something really complex like
maybe even webassembly they were there
they showed empathy and compassion and I
think a lot of times maybe as these
things are evolving we might lose out on
that so like one of the things I like to
remind our engineering teams is to
continue to continue to show that
empathy we work with a diverse group of
people that are 50 engineers and I think
you know one of the things we like to do
is just make sure that we're not too
emotional about the our code review
process yeah you get a twenty page CR
and you might want to just be a little
more empathetic about you know that
process of how you review that code but
also when it comes to you like pair
programming and taking the time to
actually help other engineers getting to
understand a particular function so yeah
that's the biggest lesson I hope
everyone takes away from from at least
what I'm presenting on and that's
actually it that's my presentation so
thank you everyone we're out of time
also right next right next to us is our
a Tobias lounge you can meet our awesome
other engineering managers and we're
hiring so hit us up thank you
[Applause]